let's go to psy from texas psy from
texas you're on the air
david i just had a one question yes
please speak up sigh so we can hear you
uh sure is this okay yeah that's better
uh yeah so
what are your thoughts on i guess uh the
democrats
uh promising two thousand dollar checks
and i guess
flip-flopping to 1400 checks instead
right i personally don't i would take
anything but
i've seen a lot of uh i guess criticism
from
mainly more the left like uh far left
um so i was just wondering i think it's
a fair criticism so listen i mean
when when they first started talking
about the 1.9 trillion
um you could more plausibly make the
argument that like listen they supported
2
000 in december and since
people got 600 another 1400 gets us to
the total of 2
000. like okay i kind of get that but
at this point by the time people get any
money it'll probably be march it'll be
almost four months later
so i believe that it should be 2 000 not
not get us to a total of two thousand i
think it should just be two thousand so
i don't like it like you i believe that
getting 1400 to people
is still so much better than nothing and
hopefully cases will continue coming
down
the economy will start to recover etc
but i don't like it for me when when
they said 2000
the way i understood it was 2 000
more not 1400 to get us to a total of
two
and so i don't i don't like it one bit
okay
yeah all right thank you so much
appreciate it thank you
great to hear from you